our next guest that ring especially true
when two co-workers who had known each
other for years
discovered something shocking through a
mutual friend on facebook take a look
meet sandy sandrick and alan tucker two
friends and co-workers with quite a
story to share
my name is sandy sandrick i was born in
phoenix arizona
i am currently a trauma nurse at santa
thunderbird medical center
my name is alan tucker i grew up in a
little town in kansas
i am currently a trauma nurse at banner
thunderbird
medical center when i was 11 my parents
told me i was adopted
they told me who my birth mother was but
they didn't have any information about
my birth father
sandy and alan are both now married with
children and interestingly enough
have more than that in common my
adopted parents passed away then then my
birth mother got in contact with me
she told me that my biological dad would
want to know that i was okay
she just blurted his name out and said
he would be interested to meet you
so i sent him a private message on
facebook
and when i looked at his friend list
that's when i saw allen's name
one day i came to work i saw
sandy and she looked a little nervous
when i saw him i told him that i needed
to talk to him i needed to ask him a
question he said how do you know
this guy gary and he said why how do you
know gary
it was kind of this unreal moment
that felt right it was a moment
that would change their lives forever
okay sandy and alan are here now sandy
allen hi
hi how are you guys
good how are you good i'm so excited to
talk about your story so you come
together
you ask how you know gary
what happens next he said
that he was his dad and i said it was my
dad too
what is the first sort of thing that you
say after that realization
oh wow uh that was quite a day
we were busy at work we were doing
traumas
and kovid and uh throughout the day it
just kind of sunk in
uh we have the same father and she's my
sister
yeah do you like check in and you're
like hey me again okay by the way how
crazy is that sibling thing okay
okay yeah i mean it's so mind-blowing
and
you know looking back now have you like
gone wow
look at all those similarities like the
fact that we do the same thing
yeah definitely we we've noticed that we
have a lot of similarities
it's crazy i'm just so glad that you
guys have been brought together and alan
you have other siblings right
um sandy have you met them i've talked
to them on the phone one time
but we're we're getting that arranged we
just work schedules and
kids schedules and all that has been
hard but we're working on that
well i have a little surprise for you
both please meet your other brothers
clint and dustin are joining us now
oh clint and dustin i'm so happy to meet
you guys
i feel like i'm in the middle of such a
wonderful
incredible family moment uh clint and
dustin did you have something that you
wanted to say to sandy
no yeah i'm just excited well
good news this is a perfect example of
what a family reunion in 2021 looks like
and
sounds like and feels like so we want to
ditch the zoom
and get you guys together and as soon as
it's safe we want you to set sail aboard
the catalina express ferry to beautiful
catalina island oh you'll enjoy
a five night stay in a luxury condo at
the hamilton cove villas
and enjoy some of the greatest beachside
cuisine courtesy of love catalina island
tourism authority and oh my gosh
then you guys can thank you
that's amazing i can't wait excited
that's exciting yep
thank you sandy allen clint and dustin
for
sharing this with us we can't wait to
check back in
and hear all about it congratulations on
finding each other
thank you so much